I've got nothing against your friends I  like your friends little things have  obviously changed for us I have to help  Charles finish his movie be good for you  to spend some time with kids you go on  Ralph cameras and monster makeup could  you close your eyes with yeah  and eastbound freighter derailed what  the cargo was on that freighter we don't  know we can't tell anyone no I  understand you have concerns about our  cargo colonel there isn't anything else  that I should know it sir I can assure  you the answer is no we've gotten calls  from people who found local dogs but the  calls coming in aren't local it's like  they all just ran away  I've got property damage I've got theft  I've got nine people missing now who  that things happening around here that I  can't explain  you  I feel good about this  go  no one believes me  what the hell